[Musique]
ce week-end certains ont peut être prévu
de faire des bonhommes de neige pour
ceux qui préfèrent rester au chaud
mélanie va nous montrer comment préparer
mardi gras bonjour mais l'agent qui a
mis et oui le mardi 13 février on se
déguise les écoles et les rues devraient
se voir envahi par les princesses les
pirates et autres super héros et pour
compléter un déguisement souvent on met
un masque
aujourd'hui je vous propose donc d'en
faire un et pas besoin de beaucoup de
matériel donc comme toujours on essaie
de faire de la récupération pour
aujourd'hui nous faut des feuilles de
papier épais pour dessein de la colle
une paire de ciseaux un stylo un patron
des feutres des paillettes et des plumes
à une fois le tout rassembler première
étape
oui on s'occupe déjà de faire le masque
en premier on le dessine grâce à un
patron ce patron alors soit vous le
destinez ça vous pouvez aussi le
récupérer sur internet mes talents de
dessinatrice fait tant ceux qui sont
j'ai choisi un patron déjà fait ensuite
on découpe comme on le voit à l'écran et
on n'oublie surtout pas elle les yeux et
les trous pour passer l'élastique la
deuxième étape alors on passe à la
couleur on passe à la couleur alors on
va le voir tout de suite sur les images
moi j'ai choisi de faire un masque unis
tout bleu bien sûr vous pouvez faire
tout ce que vous souhaitez davantage
c'est de se faire plaisir
moi je les fais avec du feutre mais
pourquoi pas aussi utilisé de la
peinture et même directement des
feuilles de couleur et nouvelle étape
la décoration sa décoration là on fait
aussi tout ce qu'on veut on utilise des
paillettes des plumes des gommettes des
perles
le choix est vaste et bien sûr le masque
sera terminé il faut surtout pas oublier
un petit fils ali oui exactement un peu
comme ce que j'ai vécu je devais ramener
officielle pour vous montrer que c'est
pas grave parce que mélanie vous avions
montré on peut quand même les mettre
devant les yeux on peut voir un petit
peu ce que ça ce que ça donne
voilà voilà donc tous à déguisements
tout simple et vous avez également fait
pour des super héros dans ces pousses
princesse à ses puces princesse pour
globale et transparente en mode
renaissance aussi et puis bon voila j'ai
pensé bien réagi aux plus grands aussi
sa créativité c'est normal merci
beaucoup mais la vie